i'm gonna be honest with you
when when season two came out like they
were it was about to come out it was
like
it's not gonna be anything like season
one loved it
like it was better than season one that
rarely happened
it really happened
i loved the new editions i loved y'all
loved the sisters coming i loved all of
it i love the whole new story i love the
diverse cast i love that i loved the
kill the tension was nice um but i'm
just curious if you all have like a
favorite part of like season two like
either while you were shooting maybe
something we didn't know that happened
or just a part of the show
oh i think my favorite scene to shoot
from season two was the holy scene in
episode six just because you know i
think
you never really know how people are
gonna react to certain scenes right like
you hope for the best and you can feel
passionate but when we were feeling when
we were filming that scene i think all
of us including the crew felt this sense
of like oh my goodness we're kind of
making history i don't think we've ever
seen something like this on screen
before yeah and it it looked very
different to other scenes in the show
and yeah
so
it's really special to me because it it
just feels so monumental yeah something
like new and fresh yeah
that should have been heavy yeah i like
that what's your favorite
i mean i have to i always love dancing
with luke newton
he's on a mate but he is like the best
dancer because he's musical theater
trained so that boy can sing dan's act
he can do oh he's like one of those old
school movie stars oh 100 i don't think
i'm allowed to say old school anymore
but i just did it he just sent me a
picture of him i have to show it to you
for a fitting for season three and oh my
gosh
i felt very weird i was like luke
wait wait wait wait wait wait yeah so
you're just like already filming we're
already getting things no we're not
filming yet but the fittings take a long
time because they make everything custom
literally everything oh my god i
fluctuate like so much like does that
work out like i said i was like you know
what if i like become a bodybuilder they
were like that's chill we'll work around
you or if you like
[Music]
you